hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's hello my friend are
you getting any closer or not I can't
quite tell anyway we're back in -
knock-knock could've sworn I saw
something how the corner of my ah but
apparently new okay so what we need to
do is well Frank a rock I guess we just
need to do the same thing we've been
doing just me go get the time yes I know
it used to sleep right here what used to
sleep right here what do you mean how
about I don't know but this clock in the
real world has almost come full around
full circle it's almost dawn in this
world in fact I think that only one more
time around would make it a full circle
in this world I don't know though I
don't know though who's knocking the
doors open don't know don't care
long hair don't care need to find the
girl I'm gonna find you I'm gonna get
you get to get to get you one way or
another some songs like that are
actually quite sinister if you sing them
a certain way one way or another or
maybe that is already a sinister song
you have no idea good
I don't really know nor do I care at
this point yeah okay keep your eyes out
guys watch out for moose men and little
girls no thank you don't want any I see
you you leafy bastard and I see your
trees with your eyeballs in your faces
your mouths all gnarly oh this is not
good well here's the house but I know
that's not gonna help me because pretty
soon afterwards
apparently when I find the girl I'm not
gonna be able to find the house again
where are you that is not the little
girl
Oh God oh wow almost ran right into you
you've been going from the left you're
kind of hard to see you son of [ __ ]
well whatever I won't hold that against
you I don't hold anything against the
denizens of this forest
come on oh I'm almost out of time more
than halfway out of time
oh oh if I after I find the little girl
if the house is also hard to find I'm
gonna be very very boned I'm gonna be so
boned no that's a leafy thingy God dang
it
pingas pingas pingas oh god she's
nowhere to be found
she's nowhere to be found unless you
guys star it's good for you maybe you
did I didn't damn it I'm almost out of
time this sucks balls deep and the
shadow on the wall okay dang it I don't
know I don't know what to do god
flip-flopper flama flu B I'm not gonna
be able to find it oh ah
she'd know where she is exactly know
where this is baloney
this is baloney she is Noah malarkey
even oh I hear someone calling in the
distance hello you leave me by yesterd
nope I'm out of time fudge why is this
sometimes superdude Paul there she is
Oh Oh now you show up oh now I can't
even get to there we go now of all times
you should what
Marfan oh girl rose up prepare Annette
Winkie Nass tree what this seems to be a
big hole in whatever the hell that is
day and night in this what what am I
looking at I guess it won't matter
because if I don't get to the house
right away it's all gonna be for naught
because I'm already going insane
yep I'm pretty much insane at this point
the house
no God owes right there ah who's right
there why do you tease me no it was
right there right there ah ah ah what
the hell you gotta be kidding me
you thinking with me yeah uh that is so
unfair game why would you program it to
fail I did nothing wrong
did I I don't know I damn it I was so
close maybe that's just randomness gone
wrong but I feel like I was cheated
there I was right there and I didn't
waste any time getting to the girl and
as soon as I did she was one my
grandfather felt that this time was near
he became quite focused he didn't want
to die without something on his
conscience there was something he hadn't
finished still hadn't understood I don't
know if he ever managed in the end I was
still very young then okay ah he's
singing sometimes he just says seemingly
inconsequential stories did I don't know
if relates to the current storyline
earth who's just him rambling I have a
feeling it's ladder which means da da da
da da da da what have you say min oh
that was so I feel so cheated there
there she is [ __ ] right there there I
felt she didn't know I've been redeemed
shabu ski yeah
yes whoa
what this might be symbolic if you see
those are rooms to the house inside of
his head which is filled of thorns so
the house is inside his mind the house
isn't real in any place it's all a dream
maybe that's what it means I don't know
could be could not be you never know you
never know
halt fall a strange and unthinkable
world appeared to me through the trees
my duty is to record the changes in the
world but how can I even be sure if any
of this is real
exactly exactly maybe the forest is
analogous for his mind because they were
thorns coming out of the picture
therefore the the the forest is a
reputation representation of his current
state of mind he's always gonna be
sleeping here for he's always going to
be slipping in and out of these fake
world two sides of the same coin both
inside of his own head maybe more maybe
I'm just reaching either could be just
me trying to make sense of something
that not but that's my best guess
I'm guessing this live on the air though
I don't really have I'll try now if the
house turns out to be a douche end
doesn't show up for days I'm gonna be
very upset very upset
come on house come on come on just put
on a little play maybe I gotta summon
the house of my dances oh come on oh
come on why's it always got to be down
to the wire what can't it be comfortably
in time like last time in the last
episode of knock-knock
where markiplier doesn't lose his mind I
see you there
ah god damn it come on come in I almost
ran into that guy but I didn't I thought
I was gone out but then I did oh come on
Oh where's the dang house oh don't run
out my clock come on oh I'm pacing back
and forth trying to cover as much ground
as
possible it's just um here oh god no
don't make me run out of time don't make
me run out of time please anything
please give me the house Oh God
oh god no no you can't do this to me why
what am I doing wrong
what am I doing wrong ah no I'm gonna
lose my mind oh no no no no no no no
give me the house where's the house no I
see you there oh the house I saw it it
was there Oh God
why is it gonna be down to the wire oh
god please let me get there in time
Oh God huh why is he why you gotta be
like that why you gotta be down to the
wire are you gonna be like that man are
you gonna do that to me we're yella
why do you have to do that to me why you
guys do that to me man I think I do that
to me how long now I'm definitely awake
you thought that before
whatever where's he gonna do that to me
why would it do that to me is it just
totally ass random because of it it is
it's still a dick if it is it's still
kind of a dick maybe I shouldn't use
those right away maybe I should find
them all and then use them all in a row
I don't know I think I know how to play
this game okay there's the front door I
think it where's the stuff ah can barely
see but I think it's mostly laid out
underground oh my heart is like pounding
and my the big white crack at what the
hell where's am I supposed to go I don't
know
oh man my heart can't take this okay
here are crying gotta go find her I'll
find your baby it's gonna imagine now
yeah nothing important what did I just
walk through something damn it I did
didn't I
maybe something has changed okay baby
I'll come find you I'm gonna find you oh
I'll find you baby don't you worry don't
you worry about a thing by now but get
out uh-huh
I found you baby I got you don't worry I
got you do don't you cry no more Bannon
and down whoa whoa whoa whoa did you see
that thing face
did you see its face that was not what I
wanted
holy God did you see it
face god damn it god damn it
good god oh god not again I think the
top bar is a representation of just how
much sanity I have left which is Nidal I
still don't know if you're helping me in
that don't do this I'm gonna do it
listen I listen I heard something go out
okay that doesn't help me
wait I am still uh okay that's all the
way in the basement so that doesn't
bother me at all
Oh got some else to imagine like a time
thing shut up okay I'm I apologize for
my previous statement yo I don't care if
you're crying hello its face cause you
see it you see it there Oh God
oh maybe it was a hint the invisible
tried to explain where to find it
perhaps I should have saved her at least
memorize those cute little leaves but
then I simply didn't want to sing think
about it the invisible is the girl god
damn it that was gigantic it was only a
dream I'm dreaming right now I just have
to figure out how to wake up good good
but um yeah you got God oh you almost
got me there you [ __ ] but you did not
hanging can I imagine the time thing in
here please that would be very nope ha
ha that I almost got me you did wave me
I need another cigarette before I thank
you you need from
outside your home don't kick
I don't care where my home is little
girl the invisible was the girl that the
guy his father was talking about and I'm
assuming that that actually is a whole
thing oh that was a doppelganger
that was a doppelganger now the doobly
goner
oh I don't care hey did I hear it I'll
be still right here oh I'll be so still
until dawn girl I'm still freaked out at
the baby's things faced it looked like
it's crying baby it was like your baby
but messed up in like a lot of ways this
game is especially dangerous because the
guests start it sooner or later you will
hear a voice saying who isn't ready yet
after some time he then says you are
ready because you are frozen blame
yourself for here I come after that they
find you no matter what you are doing
and everything begins again this game
feels impossible to win the key is this
is a game for the brave in the reality
one hides by standing in place as long
as even one person is that is in the
house is still hiding the game will
continue but the game has to be finished
whoever sees it to the end is the winner
sounds like a game I don't want to play
just being perfectly honest here oh this
game is stressful this game is very
stressful
very stressful but that'll do it for
this one again it'll do it alright oh my
god this game is getting to me man this
game is getting to me guys so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation with more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
Oh
obviously a lot of
I probably should
sidetracked by